new Spike Lee movie or Artemis Fowl
right no brainer doesn't quite cover it
[Music]
defy Bloods so the five Bloods is a new
Spike Lee movie I thought it was gonna
be like Vietnam movie that takes place
during the Vietnam War
not really I mean sometimes it is so
there's this group of friends they were
in the Vietnam War together they
returned to Vietnam today to get the
body of their fallen comrade played by
chadwick boseman also to find gold that
they buried most of which a worthy quest
and from the get-go these friends meet
up in modern day and you can feel the
camaraderie there you can tell there
were old war buddies you feel the
friendship you feel the love though
differing ideologies but that's what
friendship is there's actually a really
powerful moment near the beginning word
you you understand the war is long done
but not for everybody which is one of
the big themes in this movies movies
actually quite profound with many
applicable themes for Humanity but also
first got to talk about I like how the
movie was filmed just the filmmaking
element of it when you first see
everybody they're not in the jungle of
Vietnam but they're in the city it's the
scope aspect ratio two three five aspect
ratio standard cinema you get it then
when it flashes back to Vietnam it's the
four by three aspect ratio also looks
like it was filmed in sixteen millimeter
could have been thirty-five millimeter
with some post-production tweaking but
it looked like sixteen millimeters then
when it's in modern day they get out to
the jungle it blows up to one seven
eight aspect ratio which is also known
as flat which also might be IMAX I say
that because it is really crystal clear
at that point it'd be easier to tell if
this movie came out in theaters but here
we are but the different film and
filming techniques used to really do a
good job at separating the tones I don't
know I really dug that and I dub the
transitions to that there's something
about Spike Lee I like how he he always
has a message to tell but he does it in
a stylistic Spike Lee way there's
sometimes it's heavy because he'll talk
about something and you will see graphic
imagery of that it's heavier like I mean
at first I was like it kind of pulled me
out of the movie a bit but it was
undeniably more effective cuz it's easy
to hear about something you go okay that
must have sucked when the artists or
filmmakers like now you got a look at it
you can't just go oh well maybe
I'll google it later now you're made to
see the horrors now so I actually
appreciated the technique also the
movies remarkably intense I just didn't
expect thrilling shootouts some of it
felt a little chopped up but the
firefights were still intense one scene
in particular not a war scene that was
the most intense scene like if you're
not gripping your seat I don't know what
to say I don't know how that's possible
anxiety inducing stuff that said I
really dug what this movie had to say
about humanity about people not only the
fact that you're following these black
soldiers who went to war in Vietnam for
America they went and fought in a war
that most people didn't believe in or a
country that didn't believe in them but
they still did it and fought as soldiers
but also what it has to say about war
and the tragedy of soldiers and the fact
that when you get out of the war zone
when you take that chopper home it's not
like your entire mindset stays there in
the battlefield now you take that [ __ ]
with you it's hard to melt that away and
when a lot of the training that
programmed your brain to be a soldier
revolved heavily around hey people who
look like this are the enemy it's easy
to carry that hate with you into
civilian life and that concept isn't
just applicable to the military or war
though this movie is using that to tell
the message example if you're a parent
who tells their kid hey people who look
like this or the enemy you're
programming your kids it's all brain
programming and brain programming is
very hard to shake off Delroy Lindo is
the look into that mindset he's actually
quite a tragedy there's this one scene
where he just gets all pissed off at
everybody and he goes into the jungle
he's literally crying as he does but it
was such a powerful scene when you look
at that and you think to yourself yeah
people who walk that path of hates just
they do so and they're clearly miserable
but they're miserable because they're
choosing to walk that path out of an act
of stubbornness you know like all you
had to do was just turn around be like
alright I'm sorry what can I say let's
walk together but people it's hard for
people to do that so I felt like this
movie had a lot to say about humanity
itself however and going a little
further with Delroy Linda's character he
is the outward Trump supporting Magga
hat-wearing
literally he wears a maggot in the movie
he's that hateful tough guy and I'd I
have thoughts about that just the
execution of it I don't think you needed
to give him a mega hat I mean obviously
it's it's Spike Lee's movie and he wants
to convey his message in his thoughts
you see that with artists that's just
the nature of film and any piece of art
this movie had enough to say about human
nature humanity hate and that is
applicable to everybody anybody who
would watch this movie anybody breathing
and living but by giving Delroy Lindo
character the mag a hat and making him
the outward Trump supporter you've now
shifted the conversation to out now it's
a political conversation it's right
versus left it's Republican versus
Democrat liberal versus conservative
before the conversations that this movie
was setting up I don't feel it had to be
which means I feel like that might
undercut the otherwise brilliant
conversations that this movie is begging
to have for a conversation anyone can
find if they just do a quick search on
Twitter
it's those conversations are everywhere
on Twitter and Spike Lee does a thing
where the themes are definitely in there
and then more than a couple times the
characters then talk about the theme
this in case the audience didn't get it
and I feel like it's just much more
effective when you let the theme speak
for itself it might reach less people
yes but for the people it does reach and
the people it does click with it's much
more impactful so it's like you
sacrifice impact with accessibility when
you have the characters explain it maybe
that's why the movie felt a little long
for me you probably could have shaved 15
minutes off of it a couple of redundant
things but regardless I really enjoyed
the five blood it's a timely message for
today but also a timeless message for
people in general I thought it was a
really good time no alcohol required
alright the five Bloods have you seen it
what did you think about it's on Netflix
now a lot of times I have to remember to
tell you where you can find it to stream
it not used to having to do that but
have you seen it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]